welcome everyone i'm not live this is a
pre-recorded video
for youtube really excited about this
one
i'm about to take the chess personality
test
this is a website which has existed for
many many years i'm pretty sure i took
this at some point
maybe sometime in my childhood but
not during my adulthood so
i'm going to find out what my chest
personality
is and what's cool about this it kind of
it will give 20 positions
and then afterwards it's going to
recommend some openings that fit my
style
we'll see how accurate that is uh which
friends are most like you this only
works if you have friends
and then oh which master i'm most like
but i am wait maybe i'm most like myself
i don't know yeah it'll be interesting
to see what uh
what or who it compares me to so uh
let's jump into it
i'm gonna leave a link to the test in
the video description
so if you want to try it yourself i
encourage you
to do it and then leave a comment below
like what
uh what you end up getting as your
personality
it'll be cool to see if there's anyone
who who matches
my personality so uh let's go into this
and just making sure the layout's okay
looks good okay so question one which
side
would you rather play in the falling
position it's black to move
i mean this just looks really nice for
white this is like a
night or looks like a night or theory
type thing
[Music]
um i should probably think about it for
a
moment here if it's blocked to move
oh blocks up a piece blocks up a piece
black has an extra bishop for a
pawn um
i'm almost positive this is some like
main line opening
of the the problem for black you can't
really
castle because can i make a move no i
can't make a move
i guess i can only click these ones you
can't castle because the king's tied
down to the bishop
or maybe you could but then you give
back the piece um
neither five is coming
or as ben feingold would say knife f5
yeah i mean it's asking which side you
would rather play
i'd much rather be white and just let my
opponents suffer
maybe g6 maybe king f8 is a move
but when you play knight f5 g7s also hit
yeah let's do white
for some of these all rely on on
intuition when you play internments
do you usually score with consistent
results
or do you often perform on this extremes
either really well or really poorly
i have to think about this one i haven't
played
i haven't played it over the war
tournament uh
since february and then before that
and it's been a while um
i think my results are usually pretty
much on the extremes
i mean when i do average it feels like i
do poorly
[Music]
um
yeah there was a point so in 2015 i had
like a lot of like really good results
it's probably when i was playing more
actively
2015 2016 and then
i followed up with some really bad
results my rating just fluctuated
uh yeah we're going to go with b
which best describes how you think about
this position in the sebastian cup
sicilian
oh this is like a main line i've played
this position for both sides
black has given up a critically what did
i do
back can i go back
i missed it i missed it
i don't know what it said i don't even
know what i clicked
ah i feel like it was one of those
answers
like both of them wait it said something
about black has given up the critically
important d5 square or black has
two bishops and counter play like both
answers would have been correct there
so um i probably would have picked white
but
okay i have to move on which statement
is closer to the truth
i bring my best game when facing
opponents i dislike
i don't really notice my opponent
what does this even mean
i mean probably b
but i i noticed my opponent in terms of
opening preparation
like every single like serious
tournament game i play
i'll look up my opponent beforehand and
get a sense of
what openings they play
and what their weaknesses are
i don't know what does it mean to
dislike an opponent
yeah i like the philosophy
like in general at least beyond the
opening play of the board not the point
so then go with b
black has just played g5 your first
instinct is to
[Music]
i mean it depends if it's like a lee
chess blitz tournament
or a serious classical tournament
i don't know maybe i just have
multi-personality disorder
okay but i'm gonna stick with like
because it's it's been asking some
questions about tournament results i'm
gonna stick with
um just my over-the-board tournament
chess
is to retreat to
[Music]
wait let's look at the position first
yeah probably to retreat to g3
because if we take on on g5 the problem
is our queen can't really get in
and the light's already defended twice
yeah retreat to g3
yes wait do i play game i
i play gambit sometimes in over the
board chess
yeah i've played budapest gambit
i can't wait to play a serious over the
board tournament
and play the stafford gambit it's gonna
happen
alexa remind me in three years or maybe
just one year to play the stafford
gambit in an
over-the-board tournament
what time december 18th 2023 should i
remember
uh noon okay
i'll remind you december 18th 2023 at
noon
thanks you're the best how would you
think about whether or not to take on g5
as white i would evaluate the placement
of the pieces i would calculate several
variations oh
um i i'd have to calculate
i mean how do you calculate here
right let's let's look into this
position knight takes g5
pawn takes g5 bishop g5
it's hard to calculate because black has
a lot of options after bishop g5
there's queen e7 there's king g7
the there's e5
i guess our plan is like e4 rook g3
and maybe some combination of f4
i'd probably be lazy yeah i'd probably
evaluate the
the placement of the pieces and just
understand the resources
like e4 rook g3
f4 f5 ideas
it's really hard to calculate concrete
variations after
like after bishop g5
let's go with a under serious time
pressure you are more likely to
oh probably both but
i guess more likely to i mean
when you move pieces aimlessly you
usually miss a tactic right
but actually so when i'm under time
pressure i like to play
i like to try and be extra solid like
minimize blunders
and move aimlessly yeah okay b
it's a good strategy because then you're
less prone to missing tactics
which of these ideas do you prefer for
white
oh i remember this i remember
looking at this position and thinking oh
knight d4
this um so we should go through both
options
white should trade bishops and put a
strong knight on d4
no i did the thing again i did the thing
again
i'm trying to think of the position so
the plans were either to
trade bishops and play knight t4 or
i think play pawn d4 at some point
i think that the knight d4 plan is kind
of nice because then we
we have f5 potential so i think i picked
the right one
i have to watch my clicking okay
you start a game out with d4 would you
rather your opponent play d5 or f5
honestly probably d5 because then i just
want to have a traditional london
and f5 is also fun but let's say d5
okay let's not click i'm going to take
my hand off the mouse
but maybe hover over you have
been you have been a pawn ahead for most
of the game
but after tough resistance from your
opponent you have only five minutes left
in this position
would you play on or offer a draw
or offer your opponent a draw wait why
would i offer a draw
should always play on yeah you should
never end the game prematurely
like this it's usually a hard rule that
i give students
like do not take draws in positions
where there's chances to win
even if you're low on time you'll learn
a lot more
it makes for better youtube content keep
pushing for a win
oh asking about my feelings okay which
statement comes closest to your feelings
it's always a joy to be paired with
someone you've crushed in the past
the odds of winning are slightly higher
against opponents
one has previously been
what it's always a joy
i mean yeah this is
true the odds of winning
are slightly higher against opponents
one has previously been
i mean this just makes this is more like
asking about emotion it's asking about
like
if it's a joy and this is just asking
about statistics
i have to go with statistics those are
more real than
feelings okay
with plenty of time on your clock who
wait whose move is it oh okay uh
so basically what would you do in this
position if you had a lot of time
assuming white to move trade on e6 when
knight takes e6
and play rook d7 because the end game is
good for white
or redirect the knight to c3
to preserve the better minor piece
invest some serious time calculating
whether 96 achieves
anything concrete
honestly i would take time if i if i had
time in this position
i would calculate i mean 96 rookie 6
rook g7
it seems pretty concrete
uh black would have to play rook one of
the rooks e7
we put the the other rook on d1 and then
we can start bringing our king in
black brings the king in
i guess if we bring our king and there's
b5
and then we oh we play king b3 b5 and
then c4
[Music]
but then c6 how do we make progress
oh maybe we we bring the other rook from
d1 to
some square like d5 and then put our
king on d4
[Music]
i guess i don't actually have to
calculate it but it's a fun position to
like dig into deeply
and that's my style in
slower tournaments like if you have time
and it's a concrete position you
calculate
it's a very important skill to have
so a is more like just rely on intuition
but
b is a better better approach
what you think of the famous saying
trust is 99
tactics uh
i have to disagree i mean it's some
percentage
some percent time management
what's that song by fort miner
80 skill 99
concentrated power of will five percent
pleasure 15
pain and 100 percent reason to remember
the name oh i disagree
okay how do you feel about this wild
gamut line for black
it's white to move obviously the pawn
just moved to d5 the queen's attacked
i have to look this up later this looks
familiar but i don't know how this came
about
um black is down a rook
can i count wait black is down the rook
and i can't count
black is down a rook in the pawn but the
knight's got a bit stuck and there's
initiative there's bishop g7 knight d4
uh so am i trying to lose or i like my
chances and this will
definitely mess with my opponent
i gotta go with b i mean this even
though this
probably doesn't fit my classical
tournament style
i would only go into this if i was
prepared and i would probably like my
chances if i was
engine prepared bishop g7 is coming
we'll win back the night there's knight
d4
let's go after losing a game
have you ever broken something or yelled
out loud
i mean not since childhood
i feel like i've yelled but i quietly
yelled
so more like just talked yeah let's say
no
i like to play in castle oh castle
kingside oh
castle kingside or queenside
i mean it's gotta be queen sign gotta
make it sharp
when you castle kingside it's so boring
it doesn't make for good youtube content
but you castle queenside there's h3
g4 g5 pawn storm knight e5
and it's hard for black to attack
actually like the the knight is um
restricted by the pawns pawn swarm for
black
like a6b5 it's a bit slow
let's go queenside which is closer to
the truth
i get excited or nervous before a game
i don't worry about prizes money titles
or honors while playing i just play my
game
almost definitely be i have been nervous
or excited before games
but
that was when i was younger or when like
it's a final round
and there's pressure but these days
it's just about playing just about
enjoying
uh enjoying the process learning process
and
and having having an interesting battle
okay almost done question 19 how would
you come up with a plan
in this position as white
just considering the position okay
oh consider the strengths and weaknesses
of black's position and decide where my
pieces feel best
i would calculate some line for white to
see how strong
various possibilities are
so it's basically asking when i rely on
intuition
or more rely on some concrete
calculation
i'd probably have to calculate like e5
constraints and weaknesses of black's
position
i mean we're assuming white to move and
there's
there's a few different captures in the
with the pawn there's e5
there's leaving the tension playing
knight f1 you have to calculate
okay which is harder for you
identify my advantages in building a
plan
trade a good position for a strong
attack
oh
identify my advantages and building a
plan
i would say be
it can be yeah when you have a good
position
i mean that can involve up material more
space better center
but when you when you say trade a good
position that means like giving away
your advantages
i guess having a strong attack could
also be a good position
but i'd rather have some what do we call
it
a more long-term advantage a strong
attack that can be short-term
it could pay off but it could not pay
off let's go with b
hey i'm a surgeon and people have to
call me doctor now
emmanuel alaska surgeons are tricky
practical players who use positional
play
to fight for a win in all positions
they usually don't gain big advantages
early in the game
and sometimes even get worse positions
but surgeon is clever
and knows how to fight also probably
knows how to do surgery
with great nerves and calculating
ability a surgeon will
uncover every hidden resource available
to bring the game to a favorable
conclusion
i think that's reasonable
so i'm a little bit more positional
[Music]
but positional aggressive it's
interesting
i definitely lean i lean on the side
towards calculating in slower games
oh i'm also calm oh
okay where to share my results twitter
or google does this even exist anymore
alexa does google plus still exist
here's something i found on the web
according to bluecorona.com
google plus still exists oh
i didn't know that it's good to know
okay that was fun i hope you will enjoy
that again leave a comment
if you want to share your own chess
personality or if you just have
random feedback and um
don't forget to subscribe on the verge
of hitting a quarter million subscribers
trying to do so before the end of the
year and i'll catch you
in the next video